so we've got a number of questions and
some of these were directed to
individuals although I think anyone
could begin the first one what
suggestions do you have for significant
issues with regard to more effectively
keeping clients with a significant
memory problems how keeping them in
treatment suggestions for keeping
patients with memory problems in
treatment it's important to acknowledge
that they're there and I feel like you
know not validating that something that
came up earlier
um can be problematic so you know not
acknowledging that and not validating
that that is an issue for somebody is I
think the first step there psychiatrist
I only have to say people will forget
what you say but they won't forget how
you made them feel so if you show
respect empathy they will come back what
comes to mind is every day we do a
research project and we make sure
everybody comes in because you want to
waste your money on page to drop out and
we always call people the night before I
give people loss better material or
reminders concrete pieces of evidence
stuff like that there is an iPhone app
actually is called my chart support that
tracks all your appointments and lab
data and actually some hospitals like
the young Haven Hospital can be synched
with this particular app please address
why children who are adopted seem to
have a higher prevalence of BPD is it
connected to their belief that
biological parents abandoned them is
this disorder genetic but complicated by
environmental issues the several
questions in there beginning with with
adoption
thoughts or comments about about the
experience of adoption on BPD or perhaps
complex trauma related actually there
were about five people asking questions
like that right after my presentation I
see what you see I see what you notice I
don't know I've heard people talk about
the injury of being a person who deep
down feels unwanted that may be true I
wouldn't know it may be that there's a
lot of genetic loading and adoptive
population but I certainly don't have
the answer to that and I think what I
need to do these two pretty good
literature search to come up with a good
answer furniture I would just point
people towards Caspi and Jack Hoffman
research about the fact that normally
genotype matters but also the exposure
to environment and sometimes people who
get adopted they get into good families
and they can mitigate the effects of
whatever genetic load they may have yeah
but I think but the question is about
and that's something that I also see is
that people get adopted back very loving
people very quickly after birth and then
have a very rocky course actually
oftentimes and so it's easy for us to
see that people get adopted and have a
very hard time before the time but we
see these problems in a high-wage right
after adoption of right after birth also
and I don't know what you can make of
them I guess I'll just add one thing I
think that John Gunderson has talked a
lot about interpersonal hypersensitivity
so this hyper sensitivity to rejection
and that's one of the really heritable
features of BPD and so I wonder if you
know there's something about that and
becoming aware you know that
you were adopted if there's some kind of
interaction there but I guess I would
point to this idea of of rejection
sensitivity as being a really core
feature of BPD that is actually quite
irritable
I have another association is you're
talking I saw patients who was adopted
and then she discovered her birth family
at age 45 or something and she walked
into her home of her siblings never
having met him and she said I'm at home
there was something about the rhythms of
the bodies of the people who had the
same genes as it is that's a similar and
I can relate to this when I you know
when I see my brothers I see so many
funny gestures that they make in ways of
giggling and laughing that fits with my
funny way of doing things and I think we
have these biological rhythms that I'm
actually fascinated by because they get
so hurt by trauma that really make us
feel comfortable with some people and
out by others and maybe there is
something on the level of biological
rhythms of being adopted by people who
have very different biological rhythm
because they don't share your genes with
you that makes it with Missa see more
difficult it's just a hypothesis there's
a question about working with reading
deficits when anyone comment on
treatment when there's reading deficits
with our work we assume that the person
doesn't and so although it looks really
heavy on handouts when you look at it we
really don't rely on handouts all that
much it's really about process and
talking and dialogue and that sort of
contextual experience between people is
really where the bulk of the work is but
for new learners of the skill system
it's helpful to have the handouts but I
think as trainers or skills coaches get
better at it it's really much more of an
interactive process and really less
reliant on reading
okay we have a question here could the
memory-recall issues be related to the
PTSD and anxiety if so should the focus
be the consistent quelling of anxiety
with grounding centering techniques so
the quit so I believe the question is is
it possible that the memory issues are
actually anxiety issues and would it
would it make sense to be treating the
anxiety by helping kind of reduce
anxiety should that be the starter
should that could that be affecting the
these memory I think that's where the
questions going comments on that on
treating the anxiety to help in memory I
think yes okay next question
Gabriela would you like to cognition we
often times give benzos to people and in
Zen I really study modern studies more
than 40% of people ended up on benzos
and this clearly is recognized that they
erase some of your memory so that
compounds to the oldest cognitive issues
that we're talking about and there are
ways to go around that however I
recognize when we cannot we cannot make
people function without I also think
that in in the case of PTSD or anxiety
and the mistrust of oneself that goes
with it that as addressing the anxiety
and bring enables more memories and then
affirmation of some way of validating
the memories reduces the anxiety okay on
a similar theme does revisiting trauma
necessarily mean recalling actual
memories of the trauma or contribute be
effective without remembering or
revisiting
details from trauma so it's kind of is
it important I think of the question
it's kind of is it important to get it
whether it's real memories isn't
necessarily important to deal with
stated memories I have two parts to that
I really had three different therapists
and three different sort of stages of
therapy and the first two were when I
was younger and I didn't know my past
but I thought I did we created something
we created a story I didn't get along
with my mother you know that sort of
thing that everybody suffered from in
the 60s but I got better and I really
sort of went on 20 years thinking I was
you know okay I was really anxious but
I'd always been anxious and I didn't
know how dissociated I was because
people didn't talk in those terms later
most of the memories initially were
physical I didn't I think the shock
treatment did um have consequences for
my memory but it didn't change what was
in my body and once I read the records
my body went crazy and I carried all of
those that information so from there I
could construct from that from Dreams
from you know I could construct a good
enough sense and then I had the good
fortune to have my brothers who came in
met with me and my therapist and
validated you know again the problems
they have the ideas they had so and then
the affirmation really does unlock makes
makes it easy to get more memories that
seem to be what valid in their own right
that the affirmation in a sense being
able to trust myself suddenly they're
just a whole lot of more information
I'd like to supplement it and that is
that the issue of trauma is not a story
about trauma the issue of trauma is at
certain you felt certain things
experienced things very much in your
body that are intolerable and so many
stress is about not being able to
tolerate what you feel and not being
able to tolerate what you know it's not
about telling a story it's about
learning to become still enough to allow
yourself to the sensations that you feel
or yourself the memories you feel to to
feel them to see them to experience them
to have them but it's not about telling
other people that story it's really
allowing yourself to know what up to now
has been unbearable to know and the
sense must be not there
for example in the EMDR if most I would
hardly ever go into stories and mostly
much of the treatment I do is very quiet
people really go into themselves
and larger cells to say no to see
remember experience themselves back then
was like for them right though there's
not much of a story and what is true or
not is actually totally irrelevant
because it's really coming to terms with
yourself and your own internal
experience basically has anyone looked
at changes in neuropsychological
functioning deficits after a long period
of DBT the person also asks about
meditation affecting cognitive
functioning as fours
I'm sorry as far as I am aware there
aren't any studies of this just yet and
this is something that we're looking at
right now in my laboratory actually this
Thursday we have one of our first few
people coming in after six months at
least of DVT and this is something that
we're interested in and I'm very curious
to see what the results might be I am
suspecting that attention and possibly
memory is what we'll see improving
through DBT but I'm not 100% sure
so I guess keep an eye out for this and
hopefully all it'll be out in the next
year - the results of this does an
emerging literature on the effect of
meditation on brain functioning eg brain
activation so neuro psych marcha that
work is being done by my colleagues in
Charleston Charlestown Massachusetts
better Herzl Sarah Lazar and again that
will be presented at that conference
that I'm trying to get you all to come
to at the end of
is our problems with mentalizing
thinking about mental states of self and
other a cognitive deficit of borderline
personality disorder that is that a
neuro psychic so so it's a question are
our problems in mentalizing thinking
about mental states of self another so
out of mentalization is that a cognitive
deficiency does that fall into kind of
our theme of this conference I think
that's the question is this a is a neuro
cognitive deficit not to be able to
think about states of self another would
anyone comments on that you asked okay
so I like to call it a social cognitive
deficit because you know whether we want
to may not realize it but you know you
need cognition in order to be able to
navigate social interaction so you
really it's really a joint process
social and cognitive functioning and and
the types of neuropsychological
functions that I talked about are
actually related to how well somebody is
able to mentalize or understand another
person's you know mental state and so
some of the research that my graduate
student has done as I mentioned earlier
has shown that in BPD there are
difficulties with understanding certain
mental states and deciphering somebody's
facial expressions if you think of what
goes into figuring out whether somebody
is happy or sad it really involves a
very sophisticated you know coordinated
set of cognitive functions to be able to
see you know is the mouth is it you know
where is it stand relative to the nose
and the side of the face so what I would
say it's social and cognitive and I
would say that there is good evidence
that this so that dumb that there are
deficits in this function in BPD I just
wanted to add one thing about folks with
intellectual disabilities that part of
the problem is when you can't establish
a good communication with
it's really hard to evaluate that the
social component of it and so I think
it's really important you know just for
us to be not assuming that folks with
intellectual disabilities don't have
certain capacities and part of it is
that we have a hard time getting you
know in that situation where we can
understand what they're saying and they
can understand what we're saying and
that they're not too vulnerable to be
able to even engage with you about it
and I think the relationship takes a
long time so I think it's hard to
evaluate it with people with those
issues there's a very extensive
literature on abuse kids how they become
extraordinarily sensitive to read danger
in people's faces have a hard time
picking up kindness a hard time picking
up concern their perceptual system gets
biased in the direction of threat a very
hard time reading positive intentions on
the part of other people extraordinarily
good in picking up negative intentions
negative it's felt like things because
the part of their brain having developed
in a youth dependent when Mary is is
focused on survival and not on having
fun what you're discussing relates to
this question the negative
interpretation of neutral facial
expressions by people with BPD is this a
kind of hyper vigilance which they it's
a hyper okay there's a question from a
mental health consumer which is about do
you have suggestions for ways a person
with BPD might orient new friends to
cognitive and emotional challenges and
this is and they they raise because of
issues of stigma as well as lack of
awareness and then the issues involved
with that so many suggestions for a
consumer given these neuro cognitive
emotional difficulties
I don't know whether I would have been
able to follow this advice myself but as
someone who used to be really secretive
and who now isn't the I think people are
especially young people are much more
flexible and open and willing to deal
with you if you kind of tell them where
you're coming from rather than when you
you know insult them and think you're
trying to weasel out of something after
the fact people are just much more
generous and accepting are there
specific emotion regulation strategies
that are affected by cognitive deficits
such as poor attention memory etc does
that does that that those deficits
creates problems with specific efforts
to emotionally regulate I think that
it's harder you know people have some
verbal problems sort of being able to
enact skills people that have
intellectual disabilities and so it's
it's more challenging for them to you
know be able to get themselves to use
certain skills but I think if we look at
what James Gross talks about about like
being able to select situations that
it's harder when you when you when
you've been sort of rigid or it's sort
of atrophied in your responses and and
sort of paralyzed in some ways it's
really hard to know options and so as
they sort of loosen up and become you
know have that wider range of experience
they can see the next steps and they can
understand what different things that
they can do say around situation
selection they don't have as many ways
to sort of you know modulate their
emotions once they are fired
attentional deployments but you know
really difficult for folks you know if
they have a hard time transitioning and
so I think it's it's all wrapped in
together so I'm not sure it's the
intellectual disability or the entire
constellation of behaviors that are
associated I would just add one thing
which is a study that one of my students
did I believe last year two years ago
and just looking at mindfulness actually
what we found is that people with better
working memory tend to have basically
better mindfulness skills and the way we
kind of interpreted that was that you
know to be mindful you know in the
moment you need to remember to be
mindful and so you know there isn't a
huge amount of research on this just yet
but I think that will start to be able
to put some pieces of the puzzle
together here and one of them at least
and this wasn't with anybody with BPD
this is actually with an undergraduate
sample but it was interesting because we
found that those who basically had
better working memory so remembering to
be mindful and those were better able to
basically focus their attention we're
basically had a better tendency a
greater tendency to be mindful so we can
maybe start to see how some of in most
aspects of emotion regulation might be
related to some of these cognitive
abilities there's another question here
about sharing with others it's directed
to dr. Sawyer
it's what social supports did you
perceive as helpful during your struggle
I guess I'm not sure what which struggle
we're talking about but if but most
recently when I read the records and I
was really at times I was really
frightened about myself and worried I
was falling apart yet I was keeping it
all a secret because I was that's just i
was afraid not to so I had but I had my
brothers and I had my husband and my my
therapist and what a an enormous support
one of my former therapists who very
much we're interested in what was
happening and very supportive and we
talked about how the fact that how they
had no idea what was what had happened
to me either
we never addressed that and also I had a
few friends that I had confided in thank
you
there's a question here it's addressed
to dr. Evander coke although others
might also want to speak to it what are
your thoughts regarding the sociated
episodes as a kind of emotional coma or
survival tactic of the brain oh it is a
survival technique and it does your
brain gets overloaded and you space out
and you disappear that's how the brain
survives how actually a lot of a survive
so it's definitely a survival technique
that that's essentially it they they
gave it two terms but it's survival
tactic yeah trial tactic so you don't
you feel safe you don't have to
dissociate anymore that's a issue that
dr. sorry dogs bark and also a video
clip once your body feels safe the need
to dissociate disappear
and that's the big issue well and we
were talking about memory I'm not sure
how you sort of in a garden-variety way
you can just so you can discern how much
is a memory problem versus dissociation
is there a progression from ADHD to BPD
in childhood the question is actually
premise the person is kind of testing
that there is and is asked for
explanation but can you say is it is
there a progression from ADHD to BPD and
if so why is that because of
insufficient treatments I'm not sure
really why but if you turn back to my
slides okay it was there oh yeah there's
that there's a five you're five times
more likely if you're a child with ADHD
to develop BPD so I'm not sure I
understand really what that longitudinal
Association is and I was talking about
this with somebody earlier but when we
go back to the history of borderline
personality disorder and thinking about
cognitive dysfunction what was often
talked about in the past was that there
that perhaps children with what they
used to call minimal brain dysfunction
have difficulties with attention and
learning and that the way that their
personality develops over time and kind
of adapts to or adjusts to those
difficulties cognitive difficulties
might be what we now called borderline
personality disorder but I've never seen
any longitudinal studies that really
link the two so it's a good question
exactly how that happens but there does
appear to be a link at least the
question is predicated on the notion
that these things actually exist Tom
Insel home runs and I'm age I was going
to go internet had to be destroyed to
show you this movie or talk about it
they call the first is parties so Tom
Insel the head of it I'm a
society they don't exist and they're
throwing out all of these diagnoses for
research purposes because they won't get
us anywhere and so but you see if you
actually if 87% of Portland personality
disorders people have DTD then we can go
to trauma literature which is voluminous
on the subject and the majority of
traumatized kids meet criteria for ADHD
they also are dissociate they also have
oppositional defiant problems on average
the kids in our network meet between
five and seven different supposedly
independent diagnoses but of course Tom
Insel said no there's not independent
diagnosis these are all categories that
are overlapped with each other and
that's why the sooner we get rid of this
current diagnostic system it better
everybody is off it just had a comment
for the people who prescribe medications
in the audience and for people who may
receive them is that the overlap is so
huge and turns out that people who have
ADHD when their adulthood because
doesn't disappear just like that once
you turn 18 they get poor care in terms
of getting stimulants or getting
appropriate ADHD medications and this is
because of misunderstanding because of
misdiagnosis a lot of people may believe
that they have bipolar and hence
stimulants would be contraindicated for
some reason so my point would be for the
prescribers in the audience to make a
trial you may actually see that people
who are all over the place with racing
thoughts calm down beautifully when they
get stimulants and I would suggest to
set clear goals sleep to get better
homework to get better and follow them
and give it a try not discard this just
because oh they may have they may get
roughed up well and such and now they're
very useful clue would be their drug of
choice because we also have the year
comorbidity with substance abuse and
people who have ADHD
would self-medicate with cocaine and I
would say that makes me mellow you know
that's funny
everybody else is that I'm getting hyper
and jittery but for me that makes me
mellow and I fell asleep afterwards that
would be a clue that it is a this person
actually has ADHD there are some more
questions specifically on the treating
ADHD with medication is there a danger
of interactions if there's other
medications on board and can ADHD meds
increase risk of agitation or
impulsivity coming back on what I said
earlier is worth a shot
and for me I have a particular fondness
for the intensive outpatient program
where we can follow people four days a
week and we can see directly what kind
of affect these medications have on
people but it's amazing to see how they
calm down and they focus in terms of
interactions with other medications
always there is this risk of adrenergic
stimulation however I found it in
theoretical I work in emergency room I
work in every setting you can imagine
and I do not see this kind of reactions
that people describe in a book so I say
again is worth a shot in terms of safety
there was in 2009 a huge review American
heiresses that shows that mixed salts
are extremely safe and actually Ritalin
even in older folks has a protective
cardiac effect you go figure well it
makes perfect sense because the weighted
stimulants work they work on working
memory and it worked on the nor Panetta
fit nerve at the nerdseum dopamine
system in the frontal lobe which does
get damaged by early childhood trauma
and so people who take these medications
by and large to concentrate better they
better pay better attention and have
better working memory be interesting to
do a DBT study with on and off
I think we'd be very interesting thing
to see how guelder's collaborates but as
I look at some duties slides I think
your guys are working very hard to take
in what you're telling it like they're
working like crazy all right together
and I wouldn't be surprised if a little
stimulant would help them to get it
better to grasp it better there was a
mention of dual diagnosis we have a
question when there is substance use and
BPD is it most helpful it take a dual
diagnosis approach or to treat the
substance use first and then the BPD we
may never get to your treating BPD so
dialectical behavioral therapy has had
numerous applications and one of them is
that's very well known very well tested
validated is about DBT in substance
abuse so why not treat both we have a
few more medication questions one was
asking about benefits and risks of
risperidone for diagnosis of BPD right
off the bat is that BPD overlaps with a
lot of other conditions so let's say you
have this overlap with mood disorder and
you have bipolar and risperidone is the
medication that worked for you then I
would say by all means keep it
the Cochrane review so improvement so
was watching improvement in all three
areas that are targeting BPD which will
be the emotional dysregulation the
irritability and the cognitive and this
is where abilify was the big winner and
the next one on down the list was
olanzapine what is true is that they
have not been huge studies with the
newer ones and unfortunately risperidone
the largest study i've seen had 49
patients so while I did mention about
the finest there being a big winner I
would mention please pay attention to
what other condition
comorbid and what your psychiatrist your
prescriber has has in mind there may be
other conditions that they're addressed
with risperidone we have a question
asking about whether alcohol could ever
be in the suggestion is prescribed
actually but whether alcohol could ever
be useful to help with personality
disorders emotional dysregulation mental
illness why or why not
I'll let psych just move on I think it's
actually a real question but that's a
great question I think it is would
anyone care to comment besides that I
use it every evening people use alcohol
for moderation every culture does it
every part of the world does is the
largest to get into altered state of
consciousness in a fairly legitimate way
and it's a good for people to letter
defenses down to have fun with cetera
of course alcohol also throughout the
centuries if you read The Iliad yourself
also find it has serves as the primary
treatment for boss very stress and when
Congress approved the extension of the
benefit of the tours of duty and abroad
for the combat soldiers I know okay that
will make another bunch of alcoholics
because with every tour of duty you make
another very large number of Alcoholics
because that's the way people treat
their PTSD and it works a little bit
until it doesn't work anymore so to be
vigilant about it now it's never useful
it's not good but the population is
we're talking about tend to go overboard
and get addicted because they're so
dysregulated so they keep trying to
desperately try to get in control of
themselves so just to mention that there
are very good prospective studies that
have shown clear benefit of moderate
alcohol consumption for other diseases
like prevention of stroke for instance
in the physician study
they say that is decreasing by 25% so
you would may say if I drink four times
as much then I'll never get a stroke
right the idea is that even when it's
clear evidence people have been
extremely reluctant to recommend it for
these reasons that becomes quickly
slippery slope we have a pair of
questions here one is about given the
cognitive deficiencies or problems in
BPD what would you think about more
somatically oriented treatments versus
more cognitive behavioral treatments
there's another question asking about
art therapy for improving visual memory
performance so I'm wondering about art
therapy I know dr. van der Kolk you're
also looking at yoga studies and if that
might be another example of a
somatically oriented thinking beyond
medications but any comments on those
sorts of more physical somatic but we
got funded by an IHS to the yoga for
post-traumatic stress disorder and have
a very large yoga program and I think
your guys I you know are companies can
be very generous for chunk psychiatrists
so I do love drug studies over the years
and our yoga studies are at least as
effective as any drug study I've ever
done for PTSD it's very helpful
you'd really learn to regulate yourself
a changes your brain change the parts of
the brain that artists or tribes refer
you to briefly over there and it changed
yourself regulatory system so there's
something about our culture which I
would like to call a deeply alcoholic
culture namely that the only way that we
really teach each other the world the
kids our patience to modulate their
their emotional arousal is this alcohol
we have a very profound alcoholic
background and I think medicine is very
sort of a post alcoholic specialty where
people think that if you are to control
you have to take a drug to put you back
on control and of course there's other
cultures like in India and China
where people have long traditions called
self-regulation and having spent time in
all those places I we have learned
several of this methods and they're very
effective in treating this very physical
decision issues and they're very
worthwhile alternatives to drugs I'd
like to thank our panel and I'd like to
thank everyone for participating in
today's conference I'd like to mention
just a few themes that came up that I'm
walking away with in terms of how our
various presentations spoke about not
being too attached to some of the
various labels that we end up with even
though we're borderline personality to
sort of conference it seems that there's
a lot more commonality to problems in
living that we try to treat and that we
can get into trouble if we get too
attached to some of our methods and that
I think there was a lot here speaking to
flexibility in that I also want to
specifically highlight within our theme
the important role of trauma while that
may not be an only explanation clear
evidence that that can be an explanation
for problems that can occur in cognition
as well as highlighting some of the work
from our last presentation in terms of
assessing the cognitive load of the
interventions were attempting to do and
the importance of being mindful
attending to that and factoring that
into interventions I thought that was a
particularly useful message to walk away
from thank you very much
you